seen you on linkedin for years i feel
like i've made it
mama made it now when i first started in
recruitment
i entered into an environment where
there were loads of really high
performers
and not so many juniors so i was kind of
like
delusional when i went in and i was like
wow this is this is some life
you can just come in and go out every
night and you know enjoy
enjoy yourself buy rolexes and nice
suits and
and i was just like i can have that
tomorrow and then i realize you can't
and it does take time and you do have to
set goals and those goals aren't just
monetary
when you look back at some of the high
performers they were just so confident
they entered every single month with
pipeline which
allowed them to be confident they were
like
just resilient as well you know when
when i saw the failures just didn't seem
to hurt them as much as it did me
for me as a junior i was like man i want
to be these guys
we got sent on a training course um
which is up in birmingham or something
like that for a week or two
and the teachers are great but i was in
a group of like 30 or 40 people
although that was good to have lots of
experienced people some not so
experienced around me to get different
perspectives
the difference i noticed moving to
darwin was that there wasn't as many
people in the group
it definitely felt more like a
one-on-one i learned
a lot faster in a smaller organization